[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: So I'm really
fascinated by the way
that context affects
consciousness.
Where set and setting meet
awareness and consciousness.
So why do people like sunrises?
Why people love sunsets?
And I think it's because it's a
moment in which we can actually
witness the transformation--
the transition from day
to night, or from night to day.
In ordinary waking states, we
cannot perceive the passing
of the moment.
And so this perception--
this increased juxtaposition
of day and night-- forces
us to be more present.
It forces an experience
of time, dilation,
that transforms how we
perceive the moment.
The moment becomes impregnated
with a sense of importance,
with a sense of meaningfulness.
The sunset context
essentially frames the moment
and induces, hopefully, a
transformative experience.
And thus we are left
with that feeling of,
oh, that was really meaningful,
or oh, that was really special.
We crave these moments, and we
work hard for these moments,
and we strive to
author these moments.
But a lot of times, they are
right there for the taking.
If only we were aware enough
to open our eyes and plug in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]